die hysterie rund um den sexismus kennt
kein halten mehr und die feminismus
bewegung ist wie eine fehlgeleitete
rakete durch die gesellschaft und griff
dabei falsch und was richtig und annabel
lee hat gute karten in der hand und das
nicht nur im spiel ein pokerface den
gerne korte nur gewählt ich mich ganz
lang nur überraschen können
für die einen ist sie ein anti
feministische city girl der rechten für
die anderen eine unabhängige powerfrau
mit spitzen mundwerk tamara wernli
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die ehemalige moderatorin von telebasel
ist heute eine prominente youtube rinn
und tag kolumnistin der basler zeitung
ihr fachgebiet gesellschaftspolitische
reizthemen was ist doch ganz klar
[Musik]
ich glaube hat gemeint dass ich halte
plan hat sich immer noch besser werden
dass ich völlig ein großes publikum
ob die lautsprache youtube kanal und
hinter sich habe
ich mache einfach und gut aber was damit
gemeint
die selfmade frau ist auf dem weg zu
einer podiumsdiskussion das thema
meinungsfreiheit passt wenn die hat so
praktisch allen kontroversen themen eine
gepfefferte meinung auf ihrem youtube
kanal waren sie nicht geeignet für
schnell beleidigte gemüter gut möglich
dass wir wegen dieser worte heute der
vorwurf des victim bleiming
entgegenschlägt vielleicht wird man mich
für emotionslos und frauenfeindlich
halte wegen eines ungewöhnlichen spruchs
in einem emotionalen ausnahmezustand
gerät sollte sich gedanken über seine
eigene verklemmtheit oder aber über
seine selbstsicherheit machen
sie nehmen den frauen das recht auf
selbstbestimmte eleganz wird doch gene
mitbestimmt schönheit auch
feministischer wächterrat mit dem weg in
die neue prüderie gitarre hexenjagd
dieter herget sie ja er ist einfach der
mitveranstalter von einer
podiumsdiskussion mit seinem fang galopp
polska licht einfällt und dann werden
wir hoffentlich engagiert über
meinungsfreiheit und politische
correctness den papieren und reden und
was das jetzt gesellschaft bedeutet
galler ganze zeit auf dem wagen der vor
ihnen passiert
giuseppe gracia blick kolumnist und
medienbeauftragter des bistums chur
sieht die meinungsfreiheit in der
schweiz in gefahr
seine these der mit seinen ansichten vom
linksliberalen mainstream abweicht muss
mit sanktionen rechnen und wird von
einer selbsternannten elite therapiert
weil wir sind alles patient auf dem
podium und eigentlich alles patienten
kaum gedanken wollen
ich habe mir weiter behandelt kranke
patientin wurde dem moment wo sie die
mainstream im feminismus des
kursverlaufs das geht zurück bis vier
frauen tatsächlich emanzipierten und
tatsächlich aber gleichzeitig mit dem
gender diskurs mit dem dominierenden
stande und dem
er hat mehr zeit wohl nicht zum beispiel
meniskus kritisiert habe ich würde
headset betriebe also gehört auch zu den
bösen weil sie halt so
ich habe verschiedene pünktlich zum
nächsten krise aber ganz harmlos dass
ich finde mitmachen und
eigenverantwortlich und hört auf mit der
opferrolle das land ja dann sind sie
bereit seien der steuerklasse
schlafsäcke wiederaufersteht vom begriff
hätte mit andreas thiel einem weiteren
diskussionsteilnehmer ist wernli in
bester gesellschaft
nach körtings these alles opfer der
politischen correctness
obwohl der opfer diskurs und sich als
opfer bezeichnet
und natürlich wird auch keiner ob ich
kann ja eigentlich überall darf sage und
schreibe und ich möchte und sie tut es
auch gerade in der gender und feminismus
debatte nimmt die kolumnistin kein blatt
vor den mund und trifft damit offenbar
einen nerv
es gibt zwei arten von frauen die einen
haben spaß
sie sind mit sich im reinen handeln
selbstbestimmt strahlen zuversicht aus
sie leben dass frau sein zelebrieren
ihre deckelte es uns die weiblichkeit
die anerkennung dafür nehmen sie dankbar
an die anderen dies sind neidisch
frustriert hypersensibel der import
regen sich über unterwäsche plakate auf
über lustige werbung auch den blick aufs
dekolleté halten sie für sexuelle
belästigung ein kompliment für einen
übergriff und den host hessen job für
die reinste demütigung diese frauen sind
durchdrungen von dem verlangen alle
bereiche in denen sie nicht mithalten
können abzuschaffen
haben sie keinen spaß sollen auch die
anderen nicht haben die damen faseln
zwar vom frauensolidarität aber das wort
gleichschritt wäre passender weil ihr
verhalten mehrerer bei diktator
unterdrückung liegt als das seminar
unterstützung nur weil ich eine frau bin
muss ich nicht grundsätzlich solidarisch
sein mit der damenwelt die nun von ihren
erfahrungen mit feinstem typen in den
sozialen
medien berichtet ich muss diese werde
uneingeschränkt glauben noch ein stimmen
in diesen kanon der opfer symbiose der
streckenweise überraschend unreflektiert
daher nicht kritisieren termin ist muss
vor jedem ihr ebene will ich find das es
zu feministisch so in der heutigen form
wird sich jetzt präsentiert nun grün
bucht in unserer gesellschaft will sehen
uns weg vom feminismus ist ursprünglich
gesägt gleichberechtigung zwischen mann
und frau zwischen vermutliche chancen
wir haben das wir haben das erreicht in
der schweiz in der westlichen
industrieländer haben ja chance dich hat
ihr die frage was machen machen machen
frauenquote unnötig findet wernli
lohnungleichheit größtenteils selbst
verschuldet schließlich würden frauen
die falschen schlechter bezahlten jobs
selber wählen
zudem seien viele frauen zu wenig
selbstbewusst und leistungsbereit um
sich in die männerdominierten domänen
vorzuwagen
entspanne und aber irgendwas mal appetit
oder so eine demokratie und ich habe
dort wieder entspannt sehen und leipzig
hat ein zusammen langfristige besser für
unsere gesundheit und für uns
[Applaus]
weniger hysterie
auch was die sexismus und mito debatte
anbelange das ist ihre botschaft und
dafür kriegt sie von der einen seite
applaus von der anderen wird sie als
antifeministen ausgebuht auf jeden fall
polarisiert sie und das gefällt den
medien zu sich ins rampenlicht stellt
das haus geworfen bestimmte kreise
zahlungslösung moment also erstellen wir
nicht außer haus figur für bestimmte
kreise
seit das überhaupt sei dabei auch die
regelmässig colonia in verschiedenen
tätiger ich könnte wirklich schminkt
blog aufmacht dann erstens will ich mehr
verdienen und zweiten tätigkeit das
macht die ausfahrt von provokationen und
betriebstechnik und wenn es dann halt
die negative reaktionen geht es aber
damit muss man leben muss man sich
abperlen
wie mobbing erlebt ich bin auch nicht
berücksichtigt wurde
vielleicht am tag diskriminiert wurde
ich bin mit sexuelle übergriffe von dirk
sie ihre haustiere aus erlebtem im leben
und jetzt besonders auf der glücklichen
seite
so sind einige sachen vorgefallen war
ich nie sehr zu klagen haben jedes mal
aber nicht einmal was mehr in synchro
finde man sind schuld selbst ist die
frau so wörtlich devise bereits vor 20
jahren machte sie sich selbstständig und
hat heute ihre eigene firma im
kommunikationsbereich die videos für
ihren youtube kanal produziert sie in
eigenregie
das wohnzimmer ist auch ihr studio die
gemüter sind nach dem cavallo fall noch
nicht beruhigt da steht der nächste
vergewaltigungs-vorwurf auf den
frontseiten die schlinge liegt jetzt um
cristiano ronaldos hals also die besten
50 befragten geht das meistens die
besten videos
die ausgebildete marketing planerin und
pr fachfrau erreicht mit ihren videos
auch mal eine viertel million zuschauer
seit ihre videos auf dem
liberal-konservativen bis rechts
populistischen online-magazin tisches
einblick aufgeschaltet werden hat sie
viel deutsches publikum und kriegt unter
anderem zuspruch aus dem politischen
umfeld der afc
die solo und ja also kontrolliert nur
bis acht kreise aber die ganze mit
bochums lopau und sehen ob wir haben
hier folgt die cvp präsident gehabt
findet mini videos gut like situation
der fdp ist jetzt macht er sich
wahrscheinlich nicht oder video
ich glaube aber wichtiger das wo ich
versuche transportiert wo ich will sagen
ich habe wichtigeres davos an
verschluckt schreibt mir eure gedanken
ich würde mich darüber freuen folgt mir
auch bei twitter
und wenn ihr mich unterstützen wollt
dann macht werbung für meinen kanal
danke bis zum nächsten mal und tisch
bern leser und abonnenten sind aktiv ein
video von ihr wird bis zu 2.000 mal
kommentiert meist von männern und denen
geht es nicht immer nur um den inhalt
die 45 jährige baslerin hält sich gerne
in männerwelten auf auch in diesem spiel
call of duty wird vor allem von jungen
männern gespielt
ich finde es einfach lustig ist super g
[Gelächter]
wo man kriegt er wie immer wieder
freundschaftsanfragen ist dank im moment
ihr 12 oder 13 jährige wusste war sie
ihre freundschaft auf vox handeln oder
wenn wir gleich die lage zum spielen und
so bist du als einzelkind aufgewachsen
ohne politik und französische
philosophen wie sie einmal schrieb
weiter marbella ende der 80er jahre als
bremerin scheel in der basler hip hop
szene unterwegs
auch das eine männerdominierte welt
daniel dreimal versucht stark
selbstbewusst sie mit auf der waage
also sie haben immer wieder gesagt wenn
du willst du alle ist aber du musst
welle und ihre videos natürlich nicht
weiter frieren und wie immer halt alle
irgendwann unsere planungen nicht was
der schule unterhalten und ich hätte so
wählen ob sie haben sich sehr stark sei
dialog wenn du jetzt nicht will wird es
später schwer habe ja wahrscheinlich
peter schössow praktisch jeder hat
versucht so viele probleme möglich
selbständig lösen und nicht nach hilfe
fragen und nicht durch eine andere zu
lassen versuchen es am besten wenn es
möglich ist konsequente eigenständigkeit
auch in der ehe
wärme ist verheiratet über ihren mann
möchte sie in diesem fehlen jedoch nicht
reden
die rolle als hausfrau und mutter kam
für sie nie in frage
vor kurzem hätte sie eine politische
karriere einschlagen können die fdp
basel wollte sie als kandidatin für die
kommenden nationalratswahlen gewinnen
wärme die sich als liberal bezeichnet
lehnte ab sie wolle sich auf ihre
publizistischen tätigkeiten
konzentrieren und sie lässt sich sowieso
nicht gerne einen politischen lager
zuordnen wie zum beispiel führt er vor
allem auf das adoptionsrecht für alle
ich geh für teppich b führt eric von
cannabis ich hatte gar nicht position
ich glaube nämlich oder klimawandel
ich glaube der menschen gemacht das wird
zum beispiel nur zweimal in der woche
vielleicht assistenzcoach
[Musik]
poster girl der neuen rechten so wollte
die journalistin michelle binswanger
wernli in einem ihrer artikel eigentlich
bezeichnen
doch nach ihren recherchen und einem
gespräch mit wernli hat sie ihre
anfängliche meinung revidiert die beiden
treffen sich nun sogar regelmäßig zum
kaffee auch wenn sie das heu nicht immer
auf derselben bühne haben gerade in
puncto feminismus und wenn man natürlich
sagen was passiert wenn ich pro track
haut an und sei hinter dass frauen zu
mir verbieten sie ihre geschichte
erzählen wie sie eine ganze stunde gegen
michael llodra jo ok argumentiere
natürlich eine privilegierte situation
als privilegiert saerbeck wird und dass
ich nicht für alle frauen so einfach da
wo das nicht so ist dies aber wirklich
wichtig dass sie träumen von
organisationen für initiative wurde die
chancengleichheit
welche botschaft aber uns fragen oder
vor allem an die junge frau schwamm und
in uns unterdrücktes patriarchats börse
haltet uns klar und gut dass wir uns
geschaffen ich keine wahl gelassen ich
mich auf die schmerzen
wir sind doch mit schutzlosen relais
oder hilft bei den frauen sind doch
genauso können genauso stark sie will
mama mehr sehen vorlage zum teil wir
sind manipulativ mehr sind verschlagen
während das alles arme sind nicht die
heilige nacht hilferufe von der
gesellschaft oder vom staat aber ist es
dann nicht schluss die deswegen ist das
alles über bord warfen wenn man das dann
schauen sie doch starke frauen man halt
die mittel ähnlich gesehen zum beispiel
so missbraucht hat dort wo extrem
schwierige geschäft
familie natürlich dass sich ganz andere
geschichte und da kann ich mir gar nicht
wirklich und ich nehme gar nicht
übersättigt firewalls bestehen oder
sagen sie sollen morgen und sie sind
stark sellschaft das problem es ist ein
männerproblem und da werde ich mich aber
dagegen sich nicht extra schafft's
problem wenn sexismus geht oder wenn man
frauen unterdrücken
wir sind das individuell war das machen
aber nicht alle machen und damit die
ganze gesellschaft oder stoffen muss man
unterscheiden
radikale für wenig geld nicht
tamara förmlich spiel geht weiter
ihr ziel noch mehr publikum ihr einsatz
koketterie provokation und überraschung
böse sieht und der böse wie sie mal
würde ich eher oder für appelliere hate
und auch selber einmal hinterfragen wenn
es irgendwo nicht wieder gott versucht
er neue lösung bildet euch wieder lernen
besser nicht verhandele zum beispiel mit
dem verhandelt ab denn statt also
ständig der fahrer bei der andere so hat
die gesellschaft oder der böse mann
stelle doch oft hin dabei und macht man
selber bis
[Musik]